je dis on s'attend donc à une journée
noire avec des des mobilisations fortes
je crois qu'il y a 70% des profs qui
seront en grève dans les écoles
maternelles et primaires il va y avoir
des
le trafic va être interrompu à la SNCF à
la RATP il peut y avoir des baisses de
production de d'énergie dans les
industries électriques et gaziens qui
sont un régime spécial
à l'hôpital il va y avoir aussi une
mobilisation importante même si les
soignants ont souvent manifeste souvent
avec un brassard et en assurant leur
poste mais donc bon voilà il y a un
climat qui est
explosif dans les régimes spéciaux dans
la fonction publique dans le privé
on a moins de remonter on sait pas trop
mais il y a aussi par exemple le patron
du Crédit Mutuel qui aujourd'hui disait
qu'il était contre la réforme des
retraites donc oui personnellement il a
commencé à travailler très jeune c'est
pour ça non et puis je crois qu'il était
à la CFDT donc voilà donc voilà il va y
avoir du monde dans virus ça va être une
journée une journée noire après la
question est de savoir si ça va tenir si
la contestation va tenir si les
syndicats vont être débordés par leurs
bases débordé par le ce phénomène récent
des collectif
et puis les bons la bataille de la rue
elle n'est pas gagnée parce que il y
avait un sondage ce matin qui montrait
que les Français
étaient convaincus de la nécessité d'une
réforme les Français ont compris qu'il y
avait un allongement de l'espérance de
vie que le régime les régimes de
retraite étaient déficitaires sur les 25
prochaines années que si on ne faisait
rien le régime para répartition était
mis en danger donc les une forme de
résignation finalement depuis le temps
qu'on parle de cette réforme des
retraites depuis 2017 mais bon il y a
une forme de résignation
et donc on va voir si si il y a
contestation va prendre et va tenir et
bon les syndicats sont unanimes donc ils
sont ils sont tous alignés mais
la stratégie n'est pas complètement
arrêtée
à savoir si on fait des mouvements un
mouvement
pérenne ou si on fait des journées sauts
de moutons certains ont été chauvés par
la loi travail en 2015 il y avait eu 14
14 journées de manifestation sur étendue
sur plusieurs plusieurs semaines au
final ils ont pas gagné donc ils se
demandent s'il faut changer de stratégie
si voilà il faut faire
d'accord
à des violences aussi
c'est une interrogation est-ce qu'il va
y avoir éruption de la violence
en 2010 il y avait pas
il y avait pas de Black Bloc à l'époque
c'est un phénomène qui est plus récent
qui a émergé justement en 2015 avec la
réforme la loi travail el khomri puis
les gilets jaunes et donc est-ce que
cette cette inconnue de la violence va
être présente c'est une ligne rouge à ne
pas franchir ça décrédibiliser aussi la
contestation donc la bataille de la rue
elle n'est pas gagnée elle n'est pas
gagnée alors ça c'est la bataille de la
rue qui peut être protéiforme il peut y
avoir ça peut être canalisé ça peut ne
pas être canalisé puis à la bataille au
Parlement alors bataille au Parlement
elle est très cadrée en fait finalement
je pose le débat 50 jours à partir du 6
février date au combien symbolique
d'ailleurs 6 février 50 jours 20 jours
pour l'Assemblée nationale si au bout de
20 jours l'Assemblée nationale n'a pas
voté bah c'est pas grave le texte il
part au Sénat après il revient comme
mission le Sénat qui est plutôt
favorable au retraite puisque c'est une
majorité de droite après ça revient à
une commission mixte paritaire et après
cette commission mixte paritaire qui
peut quand même faire trouver un terrain
d'entente on peut imaginer que ça soit
ça revienne à l'Assemblée nationale et
que ça soit voté et que dans les 50
jours tout soit
pas calé ça c'est dans l'absolu ça se
passe pas tout à fait comme ça peut-être
Charles on a des précédents c'est pas la
première fois qu'on réforme mes
retraites il y a deux précédents qui
marquent qui sont très différents l'un
de l'autre 95 ou le texte a été retiré
après une paralysie du pays 2010 ou
après des manifestations très imposantes
et importantes le texte est passé quand
même
oui on se rapproche de quelle la grande
question c'est effectivement ce qu'on
est-ce qu'on rejoue 95 ou pas du tout
il y a eu
il y a eu un autre précédent mais qui
n'est pas lié à un mouvement social mais
qui était lié à un projet de réforme en
2006 de Dominique de Villepin
réforme du Contrat Jeune
la première embauche moi la première
embauche exactement bravo
la meilleure mémoire commence je suis
pas si jeune que ça donc
c'est intéressant par rapport à la
question qu'on se pose puisque on voit
bien que
la préparation politique de cette loi
est assez bien fait et que vous avez
décrit le rythme du vote il semblerait
que cette loi sera votée il peut se
passer évidemment il peut y avoir des
incidents de séance la question
principale est de savoir si les
républicains vont rester solidaires du
projet gouvernemental mais ça ça
le cas il y a une vraie conviction de
Erik sotti dans ce sens et donc il y a
un suspense assez faible pour le moment
sur ce point là mais on a bien vu en
2006 c'est pas parce qu'une loi est
votée au parlement qu'elle est
promulguée par le Président de la
République et si la rue réussie à
construire une protestation dans la
durée si les premiers le mouvement qu'on
attend le 19 est
devient plus fort encore lors des
mobilisations ultérieures et on peut se
retrouver dans une situation où
finalement cette loi bien que votée par
le Parlement n'est pas promulgué par le
président donc je préfère à cet exemple
là parce que effectivement en revanche
si on regarde
les annales de des réformes de la
réforme des retraites et bien on voit
que jusqu'à maintenant enfin jusqu'à
depuis 95 les gouvernements ont fait ce
qu'il souhaitaient faire enfin ils ont
fait si cette souhaiter faire ils ont
renoncé aussi à un certain nombre de
d'aspects de leur réforme par exemple
Nicolas Sarkozy sur les régimes spéciaux
il a laissé beaucoup de plumes mais il a
quand même réussi à faire prévaloir
l'essentiel de ces projets même chose
pour la réforme Touraine sous François
Hollande voilà donc au fond la surprise
c'est de comprendre pourquoi ça ne
marche pas avec Macron qui se croyait
plus malin que tout le monde lors de son
premier quinquennat en proposant une
réforme systémique
ça n'a pas marché et ça n'a pas marché
peut-être que ça n'aurait on n'a pas eu
la fin de l'histoire puisque le covid a
interrompu le processus de de validation
de cette loi de
promulgation de cette loi et là on est
quand même très étonné parce que c'est
quand même une loi assez raisonnable et
il y a eu la crise du covid de même que
en 2010 et je m'arrêterai là je veux pas
être trop long en 2010 quand Nicolas
Sarkozy fait sa réforme une opinion la
comprend la soutient
parce que ils savent qu'il y a eu la
crise de 2008 donc ils comprennent que
des efforts doivent être fait
collectivement là on pourrait s'attendre
à ce que les Français
est la même analyse et c'est peut-être
d'ailleurs un peu le cas d'une certaine
façon mais malgré tout il se les
sondages montrent qu'ils sont contre
cette réforme donc il y a quelque chose
il y a un problème Macron que que qu'il
faudrait élucider qu'on va peut-être
éluciner ensemble Roland est-ce que
finalement c'est pas et Marie cé
souligner on sait pas trop dans le privé
mais est-ce que c'est est-ce que ça se
joue pas dans les rangs de la fonction
publique des agents des services publics
ce que c'est pas là que les forces de
résistance principale existent sont et
que c'est pas là que ça se joue
finalement ça se joue forcément là
puisque c'est là que les gens sont
syndiqués donc là où les syndices plus
ont des forces de mobilisation c'est
évidemment la à votre question est-ce
que le Parlement et la rue au fond c'est
le Parlement s'est joué on fait comme si
il y avait un débat il y en a plus alors
il y aura du bruit au Parlement à partir
du 6 février ça va cogner on peut faire
confiance à la nupesse et au
rassemblement national pour faire le
buzz on s'ennuiera pas ni au Parlement
ni à ceux qui ont le courage de regarder
ces débats mais l'issue est probable
plus que probable sur les 62 députés du
parti les républicains il y en a une
bonne cinquantaine qui sont prêts à
voter alors même si la petite quinzaine
qui aujourd'hui ne peut pas continuer à
pas vouloir ça suffit largement à faire
une majorité absolue le Sénat suivra
donc on peut jouer au suspense mais il y
en a pas alors il reste cette histoire
de la rue ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
les sondages ça veut dire les grèves et
ça veut dire la mobilisation dans la rue
et au fond on a toujours le même
scénario
95 2010 2017 2019 on a le même scénario
sauf que là la CFDT c'est ajouter au
syndicat qui appelle à la mobilisation
et ça n'est pas rien c'est le premier
syndicat de France notamment dans le
privé mais enfin on a chaque fois une
première journée de manière
immobilisation avec nous ministère de
l'Intérieur 800 000 personnes dans
l'ensemble de la France chaque fois le
même chiffre le syndicat disent corrigés
en disant un million et demi à deux
millions ok c'est du monde rappelons
qu'on est un pays de 68 millions
d'habitants dans lequel 51 ont plus de
18 ans un million un million et demi
c'est du monde mais il faut vraiment
être gouvernant pour avoir le sentiment
que c'est la France bon c'est comme ça
on veut pas énerver trop ce million et
demi là et ça risque d'être à peu près
la même chose la nouveauté c'est
désormais les services de renseignement
faut savoir leur prévision ça c'est une
chose qui n'existait pas avant et cette
fois-ci nous avons lu que il y avait il
prévoyait cette fois-ci 500 à 700 000
manifestants dans l'ensemble de la
France donc 50 à 80 000 à Paris c'est
des précisions inouïes
formidable ça vient de renseignement
s'ils ont raison on verra ça je dis
enfin ça veut dire à peu près pareil un
peu moins même que les fois d'avant or
je rappelle que en 95 et en 2019 on a
des gouvernements qui alors qu'ils
n'avaient que ça dans la rue on renoncé
en 95 Chirac en 95 Chirac ramène son
projet et laisse tomber purement et
simplement et en 2019 moi j'écoutais
chargé vu avec toujours un grand intérêt
mais le covid abondo à la vérité Macron
a laissé tomber il a compris que le pays
envisager comme on le dit là le pays il
semblait pas vouloir de sa retraite et
la laisser tomber et donc on a des
gouvernants qui devant des
manifestations qui ne sont pas aussi
spectaculaires qu'on le dit finissent
par se dire c'est trop dangereux de
gouverner dans ces conditions on y va
pas et d'une certaine façon on peut les
comprendre parce que la retraite c'est
incroyablement important pour les
Français dit pour les français pourrait
dire de comme tout le monde non les
Français plus que tous les autres
Européens on a un attachement alors je
lis dans beaucoup de journaux des
sociologues qui nous expliquent qu'il y
a une nouveauté c'est que les Français
sont moins attachés au travail et c'est
vrai en partie depuis le covid
l'attachement à son travail a encore
baissé mais ça fait longtemps que c'est
comme ça si vous prenez les sondages de
1946 à 1982
cette longue période la revendication
première des Français ça a toujours été
l'abaissement de l'âge de la retraite
c'est quand même inouï revendique
à 65 ans abaissement à 60 ans c'est ce
que Mitterrand a accepté de faire en 82
et depuis on arrête pas de courir après
en revenant en arrière mais ça veut dire
qu'il y a quand même en France un
attachement incroyable à la retraite et
un attachement au travail qui est moins
fort qu'ailleurs et qu'il est devenu
encore moins fort donc on comprend que
les gouvernants soient un peu inquiets
sur le papier au Parlement ça va dans la
rue c'est pas si impressionnant que ça
sans le dire attend dont je dis et
attendons surtout les semaines d'après
parce que la difficulté c'est de tenir
le calendrier que vous avez rappelé ça
nous emmène jusqu'à la fin mars arrivé à
manifester dans des conditions de
mobilisation forte et si possible de
plus en plus forte pendant aussi
longtemps c'est difficile mais c'est on
comprend qu'un gouvernement puisse être
malgré tout in en raison de ce sentiment
assez profond des Français et puis vous
avez eu trois critères mais vous avez
oublié la violence aussi j'ai entendu ce
que ce qui a été dit avec justesse est
tout à fait
est-ce que
le gouvernement est armé pour faire face
justement le pouvoir exécutif est armé
pour faire face à une rue qui pourrait
être un peu
chahuteuse
alors déjà moi je voudrais dire en
préambule que je me souviens qu'en 95
puisqu'à l'époque suivait l'Élysée et
donc j'étais à l'Assemblée et donc
ce plan Juppé il faut se souvenir que
lorsque Juppé avait présenté le plan de
sur la protection sociale
avec un volet retraite il avait été
ovationné par la majorité debout c'était
innovation et avec un accueil dans les
médias très très enthousiaste c'est pour
supprimer les régimes spéciaux oui enfin
c'était une réforme globale très très
charpenté structuré et il y avait eu un
accord un accueil dans les médias aussi
qui était très très favorable pour dire
que déjà il y avait un décalage
contenu la partie sécurité
en plus il avait une alliée qui était
Nicole nota qui d'ailleurs donc de la
sfdt qu'on a plus celle confiant de
mélats de Sarine et qui avait été
désavoués par une part par une partie de
sa base
donc c'est vrai que le donc c'est pour
montrer qu'il y avait déjà à l'époque et
que ça n'a probablement pas changé voir
ça c'est sûrement accentué un décalage
entre ce qui se passe la perception du
Parlement de la classe politique aux
médiatique et la perception du terrain
bon parce que c'est vrai qu'on puisqu'on
revenait sur 95 c'est vrai qu'à l'époque
il y avait eu les plus c'était les plus
grosses manifestations depuis 68 il y
avait il y avait jamais il y avait il y
avait eu jusqu'à 2 millions de personnes
bloqué pendant trois semaines alors
concernant les moyens du gouvernement
déjà je trouve que
le gouvernement a été assez
d'abord il y a ce changement de pied sur
sur la réforme de la retraite qui a été
un peu passé sous silence c'est-à-dire
entre la réforme on a abandonné le
système
tous les régimes puis finalement bon pas
c'est un autre régime je trouve que dans
la pédagogie le gouvernement n'a pas été
au mieux et on sent quand même que
Macron qui est assez d'ailleurs il lui
au front mais modérément il est assez
seul en fait quand même donc il a des
ministres qui montent au front il a pas
vraiment de poids lourds politiques en
réalité qui l'aide et je trouve que ça
se ressent donc si jamais il y avait des
problèmes dans la rue si effectivement
je pense que cette faiblesse politique
se fait que
ceux qui pèsent pensent déjà à l'après
et donc obligatoirement ont un soutien
un peu nuancé je pense que ça ça se
rejouerait on le retrouverait mais alors
ce qui est intéressant de ce que vous
dites c'est que justement il apparaît
pas c'est Elisabeth borne qui apparaît
le seul poids lourd qui sort un peu du
bois c'est bon
on peut pas considérer qu'Olivier du
socle de soi si connu pour voilà c'est
alors
donc vous êtes plutôt assez pessimiste
sur la capacité de pouvoir exécutif
voilà alors ce qui est intéressant
justement pour parler du Parlement parce
que c'est aussi l'axe ça se joue même si
effectivement on l'issue est assez
probable
les deux groupes qui se font entendre
que vous avez cité Roland laupes mais
surtout la France insoumise d'ailleurs
et puis le rassemblement national
ils sont tous les deux contre mais il y
en a un qui va tirer plus les marrons du
feu que l'autre peut-être non Charles
est-ce que le rassemblement national qui
ne veut pas aller dans la rue oui et ben
finalement n'est pas en position
meilleure position meilleure posture que
les filles qui en plus encombré par
toutes ces problèmes internes
si parce qu'en plus ils sont très en
phase avec leur élector qui est hostile
à cette retraite puisque au fond avec
le départ une partie des électeurs du RN
qui était plus libéraux vers Éric
Zemmour le RN se trouve
plus proche d'une base populaire et
hostile à des réformes jugées
c'est une position confortable
elle a pas en plus à prouvé qu'elle est
capable de mobiliser dans la rue et elle
peut faire
jouer la carte de la du toyu
parlementaire donc il y a un vrai
bénéfice immédiat en tout cas dans dans
l'hémicycle pour pour Marine Le Pen et
c'est vrai que du côté de Mélenchon on
connaît les tensions internes
les syndicats sont quand même dans une
position assez tendue eux aussi
vis-à-vis de Mélenchon
puisque il il
veut leur voler la vedette et il leur
impose un agenda politique qui n'est pas
exactement l'heure je crois que
notamment les réformistes Laurent Berger
a fait savoir ils ont pas du tout envie
de se retrouver récupérer par les
mélanges donc ça c'est
du point de vue tactique et dans la rue
elle-même on va voir comment ça
s'organise mais effectivement je dirais
que entre les deux grands partis
populistes de droite et de gauche c'est
plutôt le RN qui peut tirer les marrons
du feu de la protestation en même temps
la victoire elle serait d'abord celle de
enfin
si le gouvernement fait passer cette
réforme ce sera la victoire du
gouvernement contre le RN bien sûr on va
écouter d'ailleurs quelques-uns des
acteurs du débat vous allez les
retrouver facilement ça recommence pas
Martinez
le débat à l'Assemblée nationale et on
l'avait vu en 2019-2020 il est en
fonction de la mobilisation et des
grèves c'est ça qui donne le ton c'est
ça qui montre que le monde du travail le
l'argent c'est à dire les jeunes y
compris les retraités refusent cette
réforme la bataille elle se joue d'abord
dans la rue et dans les grèves dans les
entreprises et les services et je
souhaite que il y ait un relais
évidemment quand la mobilisation est
forte il y a toujours un relais à
l'Assemblée on a rencontré l'ensemble
des forces de la nupesse pour leur
donner nos positions syndicales et je
souhaite qu'elle soit reprise mais je
n'en faut bien l'endroit pour débattre
le problème là encore c'est que le
gouvernement nous dit vous aurez un
temps de débat qui sera extrêmement
réduit alors une fois qu'on a épuisé ce
temps de débat et bien c'est le texte
s'en va au Sénat et puis on laisse les
parlementaires sur leur femme un texte
peut arriver un débat peut commencer on
sait comment il commence mais on ne sait
pas comment il se termine regardez le
nombre de textes qui arriver au
Parlement à la fin moi je pense que
Emmanuel Macron si le pays venait à se
bloquer si le Parlement ne pouvait pas
faire son rôle il pourrait comme sur
l'immigration d'ailleurs peut-être
demander la vie des Français
ce temps limité au Parlement c'est parce
que c'est un texte financier c'est ça
alors là vous me prenez au dépôts
la sécurité sociale on peut faire jouer
ça
la les syndicats là ils sont unis pour
le moment ils jouent aussi une carte
qu'il aurait propre parce que ils ont
des renouvellements et là si j'étais et
la CFDT alors la CGT a effectivement un
congrès fin mars avec le renouvellement
de de Martinez donc là la bataille est
en cours pour ses successions et
c'est vrai que les finalement la
démocratie sociale n'a pas fonctionné on
a vu tout au long de cette concertation
les positions étaient tellement clivées
que le dialogue social n'était pas
possible donc maintenant place à la
démocratie parlementaire mais vous
disiez Roland tout à l'heure que
finalement il y avait pas beaucoup de
surprises à attendre que c'était plié un
peu d'avance il y a pour il y a quand
même un enjeu c'est que le texte ne soit
pas alourdi de mesures coûteuses aura
l'assemblée on peut faire confiance aux
uns et aux autres pour prêcher pour tel
profession telle Corporation et
rajouter des mesures d'accompagnement
social le gouvernement en a déjà sur les
régimes spéciaux Sarkozy finalement à la
sortie ça coûtait plus cher que c'est
toujours le problème des réformes il
faut pas que les les
mesures d'accompagnement coûtent plus
cher que les économies attendues donc là
la réforme des retraites on attend 17
milliards d'euros d'économie en 2030 de
cette du relèvement de l'âge etc
mais il y a déjà 4 milliards 8 de
mesures d'accompagnement sur la
pénibilité sur les carrières longues sur
toutes ces mesures or le panier va
encore s'agourdir probablement lors
on dit que c'est sur la pénibilité qui a
beaucoup de flou là
pénibilité enfin les débats vont être
intense sur plein de sujets mais il y a
par exemple cette à mesure sur les
pensions minimum vous avez tous entendu
parler de ce débat sur est-ce que la
mesure concerne uniquement les nouveaux
retraités ce qu'on appelle le flux ou
est-ce qu'elle va s'appliquer aussi à
tous ceux qui sont déjà partis en
retraite ce qu'on appelle le stock c'est
pas très joli mais bon c'est comme ça le
flux le stop et donc le gouvernement n'a
à priori ça s'appliquerait il y a eu du
flottement parce que le président
pendant la campagne avait dit ça
s'appliquera tout le monde et puis
ensuite ils ont fait les calculs ils ont
vu que ça coûtait très cher mais merci
disait à l'époque trois milliards
d'euros si on comptait le stock aussi 3
milliards d'euros par an de dépenses
donc ils étaient revenus en disant non
ça va pas être possible et puis
finalement ils reviennent à nouveau je
pense que ça la CFDT a beaucoup poussé
durant la concertation donc a priori ça
concernerait aussi les gens déjà parti
en retraite mais cette mesure n'est pas
inclue n'est pas le chiffrage n'est pas
inclus dans les 4 milliards 8 de
dépenses qu'on nous a annoncé au moment
de la présentation du projet donc vous
voyez comme ça le panier va pouvoir
s'alour de mesures coûteuses au
Parlement et donc l'idée c'est quand
même de tenir pour que cette réforme les
efforts de tous ne soient pas
grignoter opérer par des concessions
données à quelques-uns
je crois qu'il faut il faut peut-être
pas demander plus de courage ou
gouvernants ils ne peuvent en avoir il
s'agit si on les suit de gagner 12
milliards en 2030 qui devrait devenir
plus après et sur ce point-là il est
arrivé à convaincre plus l'opinion
publique que même je n'aurais cru
moi-même parce que je me disais après
tout on a pris tellement l'habitude de
valser avec les milliards depuis le
quoiqu'il en coûte que 12 milliards en
2030 que pas tout de suite bah si les
gens trouvent que c'est un argument
valable mais enfin il faut pas non plus
exagérer on se dit moi je suis persuadé
que la réforme coûtera 4000 heures et
demi ou 5 millions milliards de plus que
les 4 millions 8 déjà de plus et qu'on
se dit
faut remplacer par là quoi ça veut dire
que surtout les sujets alors du jour les
carrières longues le
destin des femmes dans la retraite
la pénibilité je crois que sur le
problème de qui en bénéficie tout de
suite c'est déjà pratiquement réglé on a
déjà accepté de dépenser l'idée de
passer à l'idée que on dépenserait pour
les gens déjà à la retraite mais je
pense que sur tout ça il y aura ce
qu'ils appelleront des avancées ça fait
partie
le Parlement ne peut pas devant un pays
qui sera en partie bloqué je sais pas si
ça marchera ou bien ou pas très bien la
mobilisation mais ça suffira pour faire
qu'un Parlement digne de ce nom
c'est-à-dire digne de parlementer
acceptera des dépenses supplémentaires
mais le système de retraite c'est un
système contributif c'est-à-dire que
chacun cotise certes pas pour lui-même
on n'est pas en capitalisation les
jeunes pelles les actifs pelle et
retraite de leur parents mais c'est
quand même un système on a on touche une
retraite à hauteur de ce que l'on a
cotisé alors toutes ces mesures qui sont
accordées aujourd'hui le son à des gens
qui n'ont pas cotisé pour donc essayer
de normal qu'il y ait une part de
solidarité le système a toujours
fonctionné comme ça mais
voilà
la générosité sur certaines mesures ni
la nature contributive du système et il
faut quand même que chacun s'y retrouve
au bout du compte est-ce que vous sentez
Anne que dans le pays il y a un parfum
justement de blocage
non je fais non mais je sens que ce
qu'observe enfin c'est pas que je sens
c'est que je vois je lis j'observe qui a
une sorte de fatigue enfin de
qui se traduit soit par de la
résignation soit par
l'exaspération et la fatigue elle est
liée au contexte économique général qui
qui frappe tout le monde donc c'est sûr
que cette cette réforme qui a qui
apparaît comme une manière de demander
encore des efforts
peut en venir la situation mais on peut
aussi avoir une majorité qui se dit bah
on n'a pas le choix c'est vrai qu'il y a
quelque chose qui est assez parlant
quand même c'est lorsqu'on regarde la
carte des pays qui nous entourent de
l'âge de départ à la retraite
la France est quand même ça confirme que
Roland disait tout à l'heure
donc et puis ça fait tout à l'heure on
disait que ça faisait quelques années
mais c'est en 91 de Michel Rocard il
mettait le point il mettait le faire
sauter je ne sais combien donc c'est
quand même il y a un moment où il faut
il faut il faut faire des réformes et là
c'est un peu tard et puis c'est vrai que
l'autre question qu'on se demandait
c'est pourquoi ça n'a pas été fait dans
les premiers mois
du premier quinquennat de Macron mais
oui mais difficile c'est toujours là
qu'il faut faire les réformes il y avait
de la peur là sûrement mais est-ce que
les oui Charles
intègre possible d'échec parce qu'au
fond on a le sentiment politiquement ça
peut tenir et si ça tient
les gens peuvent toujours s'animer
beaucoup dans la rue mais la réforme
sera votée un élément d'échec et 95 ce
que disait Anne sur 95
m'a fait penser à ça
si ça marche pas en 95 c'est parce que
Chirac fait le contraire de sa campagne
et donc là il y a une contradiction
sociale et et voilà donc il fait bon
donc
de la gauche a pu s'engouffrer dans
cette brèche et il y a un problème avec
Macron je disais tout à l'heure
c'est-à-dire qu'il a il a et il y a une
vidéo virale en ce moment qui circule
qui est absolument mortel pour lui et
vous demandez il apparaît nulle part on
comprend qu'il a pas reste le père il
dit brillamment pourquoi il ne faut pas
faire la réforme qu'il est en train de
faire donc il y a toujours déjà il nous
a fait le coup avec le nucléaire mais là
il nous refait le coup avec la réforme
des retraites on va la faire mais
c'est justement le truc que je voulais
pas parce que j'étais tellement
intelligent que bon donc il y a il peut
y avoir une cristallisation anti-macron
on sait bien qu'elle existe de toute
façon qui peut prendre la pas sur le
sujet des retraites qui effectivement on
a compris les Français ont pigé que bien
compris que il fallait faire la voix que
le rassemblement national d'ailleurs par
la voie de Chenu
donne tout à l'heure en disant gros si
on faisait un référendum c'est un peu ça
et on sait les Français quand il y a un
référendum il répond pas à la question
et on sait très bien que c'est pas sur
Macron que ce braque aujourd'hui les
gens qui sont aussi à la réforme c'est
sur les retraites moi je crois que les
les plus sujet du travail moi je crois
que le social dans cette période
l'emporte sur le politique après tout il
n'y a pas que barge berger qui veut pas
être envahi par la nuit Pesse Martinez
non plus les syndicats tiennent à leur
autonomie ils n'ont aucune envie
d'apparaître comme les agents des
politiques c'est tout juste ils
acceptent le contraire donc on a là à
mon avis une période qui est très
sociale qui est très difficile à
récupérer par les uns ou par les autres
alors c'est ça qui rend les choses
difficiles et en même temps mon
sentiment je dois le dire c'est que ça
ne suffira pas parce que justement c'est
un mouvement social qui n'est pas relié
par quelque chose de très fort
politiquement dans le pays et donc après
vous il y aura pas de blocage derrière
il y aura du blocage si il y a des
endroits du pays où on pourra pas
circuler on pourra pas prendre les
transports on pourra pas envoyer ces
gosses à l'école on aura du mal avec le
système de santé si ça va être une
période de plusieurs semaines peut-être
plusieurs mois difficile à passer mais
de là à dire que on peut prévoir un
blocage qui entraîne le pouvoir dans sa
chute je crois qu'on en est pas là
[Musique]